as vaccinators continue to battle the
virus
the numbers are going in the right
direction the infection rate
has shrunk to a level last seen in
summer and jab uptake has been
extremely high among priority vulnerable
groups
as the government looks to inoculate the
over 65s a fresh plea to anyone who is
eligible but reluctant to join over 14
million people
who've already been vaccinated if you're
in one of those groups
what i'd say is please come forward if
you haven't already
got an appointment to be jabbed because
the more people who get this job the
safer everybody is
the messaging particularly targeted at
bame communities
who are more likely to become severely
ill with covert but less likely to get
a jab at this clinic in north west
london
optimism and resignation i did my own
research and i'm
very satisfied with everything we all
have to take care of each other so
they're telling us that it's safe so we
will i'm fine with it
it's one of those things i think i
should get but i'm not
too sure whether it'll work or not
uptake for the vaccine has exceeded
government expectations
but no one can afford to be complacent a
doctor here told me that they were in a
race against time to protect this
community
he says messaging from gps and local
healthcare providers
is vital in continuing to build trust in
the rollout
especially in the face of a mutating
enemy as search testing for the south
african variant begins in middlesbrough
a direct message from the government to
the most vulnerable
it is not too late to get a vaccine
becky cottrell
sky news north west london